or Kelly's a bad guy obviously he pisses
on fourteen-year-olds nothing worse
nothing worse if he wasn't a bad guy and
an actual good guy this would be the
most illest song of all time because
it's s so basic and he just says what he
wants that's the thing I like about R&B
it's the thing I liked about our Kelly
songs too until I realized he pissed on
12-year olds so this is what he sings to
people in Ethiopia he's in Ethiopia
shots just to send it home another time
cite America the fact that he calls
himself Rob is really the icing on the
cake like he's like look call me Rob
Dunn
[Music]
dude did I'm sorry the greatest lyrics
of all time did you get your shots like
a badass [ __ ] singing R&B but we
still got a [ __ ] play cool by the
government keep in heavy yeah you still
need your passport even though I'm gonna
do such dirty things you still need your
passport did you get your shots on sexy
I mean son sexy thinking about a [ __ ]
girl in a doctor's office and like it
with like blinding [ __ ] neon lights
I'm sorry but did you get your passport
made my jaw drop and then when he said
[ __ ] did you get your shots I had to
pick it up off the floor like the mask
did you get your shots would you like to
come back with Rob to America least sexy
name of all time
Rob dude it's so amazing how not sexy he
made it like he you could be like I want
to travel you on over the world and take
you in my private jet pack with me go
home and make sweet love to you but he
was just like do you have you just got
right down to it do you have your
passport did you get your shots come
back with Roberts to America
so not sexy
[Music]